alright let's go - why don't we go we've
got a lot of interesting phone numbers
here let's try going to the three one
seven area code who's calling today from
three one seven hello yes that's you uh
hi David think you're taking my call I
was just wondering if Bernie dropped out
of the race do you think that Elizabeth
Warren would have the presidency for the
Democratic nomination on lockdown you
know them the math of it is not that
clear because the when you look at the
second choice the second choice is for
the supporters of the different
candidates it's not that obvious that
that's the way it would go let me see if
I pull up the morning consult 2020 state
of the Democratic Party if you said if
Bernie dropped out would it go to Warren
right yeah yeah well the number one
choice for sent the number two choice
for Sanders supporters is actually Biden
over Warren so but it's almost 50/50 so
it seems if Bernie dropped out that
Biden and Warren would basically share
her support so the math of it is not
super clear to me all right cool thank
you yeah okay very good yeah you can
look that up on morning consult in case
you're curious